the 118th Congress now under Republican
control voted yesterday for the next
speaker of the house and
no one won
Kevin McCarthy was supposed to win
McCarthy has been in house leadership
for over a dozen years he's actually
already started moving his files and
Furniture into the speaker's Suite but
McCarthy did not get the 218 votes
necessary to secure the speakership
which brought the vote to a second
ballot
now McCarthy still didn't have the votes
brought it to a third ballot still
didn't have the votes and then the house
adjourned for the night the whole
episode was somewhat embarrassing
certainly for McCarthy it was even
historic it was the first time in a
hundred years that a speaker election
went to multiple ballots but the one
thing that it was not
was surprising
people are acting shocked right now
especially the establishment Republicans
they are horrified they are clutching
their pearls
I'm not sure why because this is the
exact same thing that happened last time
Republicans had a chance to elect a
speaker back in 2015.
it's the exact same thing
by the exact same people
to the exact same guy
in 2015 when John Boehner stepped down
as Speaker Kevin McCarthy was his
presumptive successor
until some members of the House Freedom
caucus refused to go along with it and
the freedom caucus had enough votes to
block him that election did not go to
multiple ballots but only because
McCarthy bowed out of the race when he
saw that he didn't have the votes
and what happened then
exactly what is happening now
then members of both the establishment
and the freedom caucus called on Paul
Ryan to take the speakership as a
compromise candidate who was acceptable
to both sides a lot of people don't like
Paul Ryan these days because he became
extremely anti-trump and in recent years
has seemed kind of like a squish but at
the time Paul Ryan was considered one of
the more conservative members of the
House
yesterday a new compromise candidate
emerged Jim Jordan great guy strong
conservative Bona fides and also someone
who is not completely unacceptable to
the establishment
and a guy who has backed McCarthy for
speaker
the situation
is pretty much exactly the same we will
see what happens I understand why some
Republicans are backing the freedom
caucus candidate Andy Biggs
I understand why some Republicans are
backing Jim Jordan I even understand why
some Republicans are backing Kevin
McCarthy
the only thing I don't understand is how
all the political Geniuses the
politicians the pundits the
prognosticators how all of them are
completely shocked and appalled that
history is simply repeating itself I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Matt Duncan
who says Michael great news I got
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds for Christmas there we go and when
I unwrapped the book after my mom handed
it to me I heard the signature ding
after I realized what she had given me
the production crew was on top of it on
Christmas morning I'm so glad to hear
that well done Mr Davies uh thank you
Michael and everyone else there at the
daily wire for making this Christmas so
special I'm so glad that you could have
received such a magnificent gift you
know when I wake up even early in the
morning even on days like Christmas
morning I still look refreshed when I
walk out that door you know why
in large part because I trust genucel
right now head on over to geniusell.com
make the New Year all about the new you
with genusel skin care for a limited
time save over 70 7-0 off genu sales
most popular package to take care of all
your skin care needs watch those Fine
Lines forehead wrinkles sagging jawline
dark marks skin redness and even under
eye bags disappear I love geniusell you
know I stay up late drink a lot of
coffee smoke a lot of studies okay so
under eye bags have been a problem that
I've had for my life I feel so much
better now that I have Jam you sell
these guys are absolutely great I'm
always skeptical of these kinds of
products but genucel skin care can help
you turn back the clock gen you sell
right now if you go to genyourself.com
Knowles and use code Knowles kwels a
checkout every order is automatically
upgraded to free shipping that is
geniusell.com
dot com slash Knowles k o w l e s
who are the holdouts I'm Kevin McCarthy
who are the holdouts these are the
people who are being absolutely maligned
tarred and feathered by the libs and by
the squishes by the Republican
establishment and yet I look down this
list of people who are who are not
backing McCarthy
and a lot of them are some of my
absolute favorite members of Congress
so who are the people on here we've got
uh Dan Bishop Lauren bobert Josh
brushing Mike Cloud Andrew Clyde Eli
crane Matt Gates Bob good Paul gosar
Andy Harris Anna Paulina Luna Mary
Miller terrific Ralph Norman Andy ogles
Scott Perry Matt Rosendale chip Roy love
that guy Keith self and and Biggs
seeing like half a dozen names here of
of some of the people that I like most
in Congress
so I think okay
not so bad if they're if they're holding
up maybe they've got good reason to do
that now what the establishment is
saying is this is terrible this is a
horrible embarrassment for the
Republicans why is it an embarrassment
this used to happen there used to be
contested speaker races it's okay it's
okay guys take a deep breath it's gonna
be all right
we don't we you don't need to get the
speaker on the first ballot we do I have
nothing personally against Kevin
McCarthy really as far as Republican
leadership goes he's far from the worst
guy we've ever seen there but he he
wasn't born with an entitlement to
become the speaker of the house it's all
right in Democratic politics lowercase D
it can be a little bit messy it can be a
little bit untidy people can fight and
battle and try to get their committee
chairmanships and it's all it'll it'll
be just fine guys deep breath this has
happened before in fact this very fight
happened the very last time that
Republicans were able to elect a speaker
what is the debate over
what are the two sides saying right now
a representative Bob good has been going
on TV to give his side of why Kevin
McCarthy should never be the speaker
why won't we vote for Kevin McCarthy
tomorrow he's part of the problem he's
not part of the solution uh there's
nothing about Kevin McCarthy that
indicates that he will bring the change
that's needed to Washington or that's
needed to the Congress or he'll bring
the fight to fight fight against the
Biden Schumer agenda is worth it to
fight for a few hours or even a few days
to get the best possible person for
speaker
all right simple enough he says the
country is in need of dire change Kevin
McCarthy is not sufficiently
conservative and and so we should hash
it out and make sure we pick the right
speaker now now some people are saying
who cares who the speaker is the only
job of the of the speaker of the house
when the opposition party has the Senate
and the White House is just to say no
and to to stall the agenda okay that's
true but I suspect what Bob good and the
other Freedom caucus members are
thinking right now is yeah maybe the the
threshold of candidate that you need
when you are in the in the minority of
the whole government is relatively low
but once someone is established as the
speaker of the house it's not as though
if the Republicans win the Senate and
the White House next time they're just
going to boot the Republican speaker and
elect some new guy
that's not how it works once you get
that position you pretty much stay in
that position so they're saying let's
fight let's get it right now because
this could have long-term consequences
okay what's the other side Newt Gingrich
who was Speaker of the House of
Representatives for the Republicans he
has been going on TV explaining why we
need to elect Kevin McCarthy
I don't understand what they're doing
um they're not voting against Kevin
McCarthy they're voting against over 215
members of their own conference their
conference voted overwhelmingly 85
percent for McCarthy to be speaker so
this is a fight between a handful of
people and the entire rest of the
conference and they're saying they have
the right to screw up everything well
the president that sets is so do the
moderates uh so do the members from
Florida I mean any five people can get
up and say I'm now going to screw up the
conference too the choice is Kevin
McCarthy or chaos and there's nobody
going to replace Kevin because he has
far more people totally dedicated to him
than this handful of never-enders and
the result's going to be anybody who
tried to replace Kevin would face total
chaos it'll be impossible to govern so I
hope in the next 24 hours that these
this handful of members will realize
they don't have the moral right
to reject the choice of 85 percent of
their conference
I love Newt Gingrich but I don't think
his analysis is totally precise here
because it's already happened before
that that's why he says well the vast
majority of the Republicans are
supporting McCarthy and so if they don't
go with McCarthy it's just going to be
sheer cast they're not going to be able
to find a candidate that that's not true
last time the majority of Republicans
were backing McCarthy and then a small
number of Republicans held out and we
got Paul Ryan and Paul Ryan had some
success as a speaker it's true it was
like wrangling cats but that's going to
be true of anybody it's gonna be true of
Kevin McCarthy If he if he becomes the
speaker it's going to be true of Andy
Biggs if he became the speaker be true
be true of Jim Jordan and looking at
history right now looking at the times
that Kevin McCarthy has been up for this
job
and and looking at Jim Jordan emerging
as a potential compromise candidate or
some other names have been floated as
well but Jim Jordan is probably leading
the bunch
I don't know it seems certainly
plausible if not likely that you get a
compromise candidate type to take the
reins from McCarthy if McCarthy cannot
command the number of votes that are
needed to win the speakership okay which
he wasn't able to do last time and he
wasn't able to do yesterday
so maybe the Republicans seriously have
to consider an alternative I don't get
all that riled up about these house
leadership elections because my job as a
citizen is to elect the congressman
that's what I have to do but these
elections are for the congressmen to
elect their leadership
and that's a different sort of thing and
it requires a different skill set and so
I leave it up to the members but I'm
certainly not going to castigate any
members of the House Freedom caucus for
saying no we want a different leader and
the guy that 85 percent of the
conference is pushing is not acceptable
to us I have no problem with that at all
that is that is democracy in action my
friends I see no problem with that what
so ever now
the the ballot for the house speakers of
course a secret ballot even though some
members have made their votes public and
when when you want your information to
remain private and secret you've got to
check out expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com Knowles it is extremely
important to protect your online privacy
with a VPN choosing a VPN you trust is
equally important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here is why number one
expressvpn does not log your online
activity other cheap or free vpns make
money by selling your data to
advertisers not expressvpn they even
developed a trusted server technology
that makes it impossible for their
servers to store any data at all number
two speed expressvpn has engineered a
new VPN protocol that makes user speeds
faster than ever you can even stream HD
videos with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is super easy to use you've
heard me talk a lot about these
technical features here you don't need
any technical skills to get started you
just fire up the app tap one button and
you stay connected I am a Luddite it is
super easy got expressvpn right here on
my telephono right now you just click
one button it's so simple protect
yourself with the VPN I trust use MyLink
expressvpn.com Knowles today get three
months free on a one-year package exp r
e s s vpn.com
expressvpn.com Knowles
worth noting by the way
you don't need to be a member of
Congress to be the Speaker of the House
anybody could be the speaker of the
house so obviously the funniest choice
is Donald Trump
it would be so great
and by the way it would have a lot of
political benefit for Republicans who
don't want Trump to be president if
Donald Trump just became the speaker of
the house that would benefit Ron
DeSantis that would benefit other GOP
Rivals who are looking at 2024 that
would benefit the people who don't want
Donald Trump to run again in 2024 and it
would be freaking hilarious could you
imagine the State of the Union when when
Joe Biden gets up there and you've got
Donald Trump introducing him ladies and
gentlemen we please welcome sleepy
stupid Joe can't remember anything he's
definitely look at his notes he's
carrying his notes up here okay sleepy
brain dead Joe get up on it'd be
wonderful so something seriously for the
members to consider who else would be
good I don't know you can get Newt
Gingrich he was already the speaker he
was pretty effective you get Newt
Gingrich it could be anybody and I
should point out
some people have mentioned on social
media
they've floated the name of yours truly
okay and many people are talking about
it all right and I I deeply appreciate
the countless countless number of people
who are clamoring incessantly for me
Michael John Knowles yours truly your
beloved podcast host International sex
symbol to become
the next speaker of the house but I just
want to be perfectly clear I am not
interested in that job I have never
sought that office I will not accept the
speakership of the house unless the
congressman elect me to it so I just
want to be totally clear about that what
should the house do once they finally
get all of these speaker decisions
sorted out and start governing
one great idea that has been floated is
to open up a subcommittee on the
weaponization of federal agencies
a subcommittee is different than a
select committee
okay a select committee is like what
Pelosi set up to make a big hullabaloo
about the January sixth people and to
just put on a big show for the
television cameras that doesn't really
do anything a subcommittee which is what
the House Republicans are talking about
now on the weaponization of the federal
agencies of the FBI of you could go even
beyond the intelligence community of the
IRS of all these government agencies the
subcommittee has the power to consider
and introduce legislation
which is important because it raises the
possibility of reforming some
bureaucratic structures that the GOP
rightly believe uh believes poses a
threat to our system of government we've
seen this before
an example of
using the Congress to fight back against
the executive agencies would be
something like the church committee
which was formed by the senate in 1975
and the church committee looked into all
of the nefarious activities of the CIA
and uncovered a lot of bad stuff okay
the church committee uncovered things
like like
gosh MK Ultra right uh I'm trying to
think of all of there I just gave a
speech on all of the nefarious
activities of the CIA over the years
think of operation Mongoose you think
about the infiltration of the media not
just abroad but here domestically to
push government propaganda and the
church committee played a large role in
uncovering some of these activities so I
think this is really important I think
it's really necessary if it were a
subcommittee doing it that would be
great because it would actually have the
teeth to try to reform the system I'm
not saying it necessarily would be
successful but it would be the best shot
we've got
these sorts of issues
are what Republicans need to focus on
because they're not merely political
issues they're meta-political issues
it's not just about this policy or that
policy it's about the way that policy is
made
you look at an issue like immigration
immigration is not just a political
issue it's a meta-political issue
because immigration will determine
who gets to vote for what sort of things
and and which party years down the road
so it's the politics of politics
right Democrats are pushing for Mass
migration three million immigrants
coming into the country every year two
million of whom are illegal because they
rightly believe it will give them a
political advantage
well same thing here
when we're going after the weaponization
of federal agencies we're not just
talking about one
one political issue or some other
political issue we're talking about how
policy is decided and who gets to do it
who do you want to make policy for you
do you want it to be the congressman or
do you want it to be some unaccountable
bureaucrat who is a lifelong Democrat
who is going to push leftism whether the
people want it or not
even with as crazy as the Congress is I
think you'd probably rather the Congress
do that than the bureaucrats
so this could be really dangerous too
for the Republicans who do this if the
house goes ahead and and opens up the
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government
I'm reminded of the words of Chuck
Schumer
who laughed when
When Donald Trump was being attacked by
the intelligence community and there
were all sorts of leaks and dossiers and
insinuations and Schumer laughed and he
said you know never go up against the
intelligence Community they can get you
nine ways from Sunday
it was and it was it was sad in a way
but it is kind of funny he's saying yeah
you you think that we run the show over
here no way there's this deep State
they'll get you nine ways from Sunday
and so if the Congress does establish
this house subcommittee on the
weaponization of federal agencies all
I'm saying is
look out for some of its members to come
out with sex scandals okay because I
don't think that those federal agencies
are going to go down without a fight so
what else can the Congress do
pretty much that's it
I think from the Republican Congress the
best that we are going to get is lots of
Investigations lots of hearings lots of
interrogation with the C-SPAN cameras
running you're you're not going to get
legislation
for two reasons one you're not going to
get a lot of legislation because the
Democrats have the senate in the White
House and they're going to block it but
two
you're not going to get a lot of
legislation because
that that's that's just not where the
power is right now
the power is not in Congress we are not
living like a bill up on Capitol Hill
and Schoolhouse Rock we're not living
like America in the 1790s the power has
shifted and it hasn't only shifted
because bureaucrats have taken power or
even because the Congress delegated
power away to the executive agencies the
power has shifted because of really
basic
financial problems right now
study just came out shows that the
federal government's budget is in such
disarray that if they wanted to balance
the budget
the federal government would would be
required either to cut spending by 30
percent
or to raise taxes by 40 percent
neither of those things are ever going
to happen it's never going to happen
okay or they can try to find a middle
ground which would still be unacceptable
both on the spending front and on the
taxation front
no one would tolerate that
the deficit in 2022 was 1.4 trillion
dollars
the national debt is currently 31 and a
half trillion dollars and it's going to
get much more expensive than it has been
to have that even as we've been running
up that debt we've been doing it kind of
on the cheap because interest rates have
basically been zero that the interest
rates have gone way up so now just to
service that amount of debt think about
the kind of interest that you pay on
your mortgage if you have a home
mortgage
now now you're on mortgage instead of it
being a couple hundred thousand dollars
let's say it's Thirty one and a half
trillion dollars the the cost of just
servicing that debt is astronomical okay
so what does that mean for us it means
that our policy options
as legislators as Citizens as the people
executing the government not executing
like bang bang but you know in the
executive role of the government they're
rather Limited
this is why the United States has to
remain the global hegemon
okay this is why debates over our fiscal
policy or our monetary policy or our
military policy
don't seem to go anywhere
you notice that no matter which side
gets elected
the foreign policy basically Remains the
Same no matter which side gets elected
the immigration policy basically Remains
the Same no matter which side gets
elected the fiscal policy basically
Remains the Same Republicans always run
on cutting government spending they
never do it they never do it the last
time a republican cut government
spending
actually reduced the size and scope of
the government was Calvin Coolidge okay
not even Ronald Reagan was able to do it
he increased spending in many ways
the reason for that is because the U.S
has to remain the global hegemon
because if the if the U.S doesn't
dominate the world then the country is
going to collapse because our books are
completely in the red so the only reason
that we're able to run up the numbers
like this is because we are the dominant
power on the face of the Earth because
our military is the dominant power it
means our dollar is the dominant power
in in its realm and so the moment that
that goes away it's not like the country
is just very slowly and gradually going
to decline in its power it's going to
collapse and everybody knows it this is
why both parties are so keen on fighting
the war in Ukraine when the American
people don't care about Ukraine
the reason that they're doing that is
because they're playing this very
complicated game of of
rebuffing the Rival powers that are
trying to to threaten and question U.S
hegemony
that's why the United States is so
concerned over Taiwan when the American
people don't really care that much about
Taiwan
we have to do it because our whole
National policy is dependent on
remaining the big dog on Earth
and and if if you're so levered that
that that is the only thing keeping you
from a national collapse then your
members of Congress are actually not
going to be able to do very much the
president of the United States is not
going to be able to do very much and
speaking of threats to American hegemony
the NASA Chief has just raised a brand
new security threat it's not the Taliban
or the Muslim terrorists trying to blow
us up
it's not those pesky Russians filming us
doing weird things with hookers in
Moscow hotels okay and threatening our
pipelines and and energy and things like
that no no it is the Chinese
who want to conquer the Moon
now if all of these things have you
really
just dreading our political culture
you want to search for something deeper
find a little piece find a little Solace
find a little truth then you've got to
check out the Bible in year podcast with
father Mike Schmitz right now go to
ascensionpress.com if you are someone
who's always wanted to read and
understand the Bible but you're not sure
where to start check out the Bible into
your podcast from Ascension bio linear
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the United States
millions of people have listened to it
twice it has hit the number one spot on
Apple podcasts in by linear father Mike
Schmitz reads the entire Bible in 365
daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible editor your
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free on your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube plus you can follow along with a
special reading plan to help you better
understand the story unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible in a year follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that
listeners can understand the story get
this reading plan at ascensionpress.com
this is the only podcast I reliably
Listen to I simply love it if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com
to download the reading plan for free
that is ascensionpress.com Knowles to
download the reading plan for free
NASA Chief Bill Nelson says
quote it is a fact we are in a space
race and it is true that we better watch
out that China doesn't get to a place on
the moon under the guise of scientific
research and it is not beyond the realm
of possibility that they say keep out
we're here this is our territory if you
doubt that look at what they did with
the spratly islands spratly islands are
a series of islands in the South China
Sea that China has
I've gone in and basically taken over
even though they weren't supposed to do
that so it's true China is aggressing I
actually think Bill Nelson is correct in
that it's not out of the realm of
possibility
that China starts making much more
ambitious territorial claims including
to the moon it's not out of the realm of
possibility which is why
put china aside for a second even put
space exploration aside for a second
it's why the United States
needs once again to pursue a policy of
national greatness
when Newt Gingrich speaking of Newt
Gingrich ran for president in 2012.
he made this a an important part of his
campaign platform he actually made going
back to the Moon an important part of
his campaign platform
and exploring space further
because he said we need a project of
national greatness
much of our political debate for the
past 30 40 years has has
gone between two poles of a vision of
national smallness
the left which isn't is no longer
looking out to the heavens which is no
longer looking to expand America the
left which says America is evil and we
need to contract and we need to contract
our Empire and contract our claims and
our own and our own sense of of how
wonderful the country is and we need to
just look in at ever smaller circles at
just at race or sex or this kind of
identity or that kind of identity we're
basically looking at ourselves under a
microscope by the time we're through
with that vision
or the right
which has said yeah forget about
expansion forget about exploration
forget about going into space now that's
all that stuff's a waste of money well
you know what we need to do we need to
shrink everything we got to shrink the
government we got to shrink policy we
got to shrink spending we got to
privatize everything we don't know we
don't there's no such thing as a project
of national greatness there's barely
anything as as a project we're just all
individuals and you do you and I'll do
me and we all do whatever the hell we
want and we've got very little uniting
us anymore but I'll get to keep more of
my money and that's all that matters
those have been
basically the two visions
for the last 30 40 years
that's not what a great nation thinks
about
a great nation recognizes that it is a
nation that there actually are things
that bind us together we're not just a
bunch of individuals who happen to share
a plot of territory with blurry borders
that's not all we are and we're not
we're not just bags of chemicals that
amount to nothing more than the
pigmentation of our skin or our sexual
lusts
we're more than that
we are Citizens We're part of a family
at the most basic political level and
then part of a local community a
Township maybe a district a state and
ultimately we are part of a Nation we
have a national character and we have
National desires and we have National
Pursuits and Endeavors and at the at the
most basic level of political Vision we
want to pursue the good and we want to
avoid evil and we want to do stuff and
we want to go somewhere okay that's what
we need we need that Vision again
because by the way without that Vision
you are just going to dissolve into a
bunch of
random individuals airing their Petty
Grievances and it's going to happen on
the left and it's going to happen on the
right so I think Nelson is probably
right here I think Newt Gingrich was
right in 2012. I think we need to we
need to go out there
go get get a nice plot of land on the
moon and go further and and
go whether we go into space or we don't
go into space we need to have a vision
for where we're going and we need to
pursue that together in cooperation with
one another
instead however
instead of pursuing that that agenda of
of great ambition of lifting our eyes up
of making ourselves greater instead what
we're doing is degrading ourselves you
see this in New York right now New York
has just become
the sixth state in the country
to legalize human composting
what is human composting it's exactly
what it sounds like human composting is
when you die they put you in a box they
put some plants and straw
and wood around you and they leave you
in that box for 30 days until you turn
to soil and then they pour you on the
ground
mayor Governor Kathy Hogle
has added natural organic reduction
to Cremation and entombment as an
acceptable burial method
the new law defines the practice as the
quote contained accelerated conversion
of human remains to soil
in a structure room or other space in
which decomposition can occur now a
question I ask you is
is this wrong
I think most of us think this is wrong I
would say I imagine that the majority of
people listening to this show right now
would say yeah there's something kind of
wrong about this some people might say
no there isn't anything wrong but most
people have a gut feeling at least
there's something wrong about this and
then the second question
why is it wrong
that's the harder question
most people
especially the kind of people who accept
many of our culture's premises
that we should just follow our
unfettered reason and that people should
have the right to do whatever they want
to do consenting adults should have the
right to do whatever they want to do we
own our own bodies we're individuals it
is important to maximize our individual
autonomy people who believe these
premises which are not just the premises
of the crazy left they're the premises
of pretty much everybody after the
enlightenment in Liberal modernity even
many people who call themselves
conservative if you follow those
premises and that kind of logical
progression
it's very difficult to explain why it's
wrong to turn Grandma into a plot of
dirt okay and then grow your tomatoes
out of you know dear Aunt Sally
but it is wrong nevertheless
and it's it's wrong because all those
premises that we get out of liberal
modernity are are wrong too
it's wrong because
human beings have dignity
okay we are not
we are not the same thing as all the
other animals we're not the same thing
as plants we're not the same thing as
bugs we're different we're human beings
we are made in the image and likeness of
God and that is why
we have a responsibility to show some
respect
for dead bodies
that is why there are laws throughout
the Civilized World against the
desecration of bodies what does that
mean to desecrate
it's recognizing that there is an aspect
of the body as being part of your
human self that is sacred
where you shouldn't desecrate that body
but what you'll hear from the libs and
the squishes is they'll say well you
know you're entitled to all your
religious mumbo-jumbo whatever but you
can't force that on us we're a secular
society well I guess we are I guess we
are if we're now at the point where the
way that we treat dear old grandma who
loved us all our lives is the moment she
dies to throw her into The Gardens of
the pigs can eat her and and tomatoes
can grow out of her then then I guess we
are a secular society but we shouldn't
be we didn't we didn't start out as a
secular society it's not what the
founding fathers set up it's not what
the framers set up it's not what we were
until five minutes ago
but now we may have become that there's
this really really good book that is
coming out soon by a writer named
Matthew petrusic who it's being
published by word on fire and it's a
book about evangelization and ideology
and I I just did a blurb for it so I got
an advanced copy of this book but it's
really great I encourage you to
pre-order it and get the book because it
does a great job of explaining how
political issues the political debates
that we have
are just one tiny little fraction of the
broader debates that we
the the conclusions of which we are
simply assuming
I'll bring this down to earth a little
bit when we're debating a policy like
whether or not to throw Graham in the
garden
that political debate is assuming
a lot of conclusions about applied
morality
and that's kind of the next circle out
applied morality which is assuming a lot
of conclusions about morality
generally
which is assuming a lot of conclusions
about
epistemology about how we can know any
epistemologies is how we know anything
at all it's the study of knowledge how
do we know things how do we know that
certain things are true and certain
things are false certain things are good
and certain things are bad
then
you go out a circle further well that
assumes a lot of things about
anthropology we talk about anthropology
a lot when it comes to the transgender
debate what does it mean to be a human
being what is human nature can a boy
become a girl can a girl become a boy
these are going to be just assumed in a
lot of our political debates when you
move out from anthropology you get to
ontology the the question of being what
it what it means to be what it means to
exist and when you have
those questions those questions are
assuming conclusions from theology
what what is the fundamental
reality what is reality
within which all of those other
questions would exist
we unfortunately just go into these
debates blindly in many ways
and the worst part is everyone goes
blind we're not going to have you know
extremely high level scholarly debates
over every single question that comes
before the Congress
problem is though we are assuming all
sorts of conclusions about all those
really high level questions
we used to assume them with the
Prejudice of tradition with the
Prejudice of
civilization with the Prejudice of
Christianity these days we are assuming
those premises
with the prejudices of liberalism of
leftism of atheism and when you just
take all there is no God that's one
premise we're assuming or if there is a
God we can't really know anything about
him being is merely physical human
beings are just a bag of chemicals the
only way we know anything is through the
microsope and the scientific method
morality is just whatever the people
want at any given time or whatever makes
me feel good if it feels good do it and
so if grandma wants to get thrown into
the garden that's fine or if we want to
throw in the garden that's fine too well
yeah I see how you could arrive at that
stupid conclusion but you've arrived at
it by assuming all sorts of conclusions
about about higher level thinking that
are simply not true okay and the the the
prejudices has become wrote for us
because the libs
conquered the culture and it's going to
take a lot to dig ourselves out of that
but the I think the first thing we have
to do is dig Grandma out of the garden
okay and dig her out of the tomato plant
we shouldn't that is we know that is
wrong we have a wisdom of repugnance to
borrow a word from Leon Cass we know we
shouldn't do that there is nothing wrong
or irrational or stupid or uneducated
about using our law to say no you don't
get to do that
no you should you should be buried I I'm
actually against cremation as well I
know a lot of people opt for it I think
cremation makes a mockery of of
a notion that animated our culture for a
very long time which is the resurrection
of the body this is a central uh concept
of Christianity yeah yeah and and it
matters even beyond what will happen to
us in the Hereafter or at the second
coming or the final judgment because it
it gets down to the question of what is
the relationship between the soul and
the body who what am I really if the
body doesn't mean anything then
transgenderism is A-Okay right because
my true self is just my soul my body is
incidental to that if I want to chop it
up even if a little kid wants to chop it
up no big deal but I don't think that's
true I think the body does matter so
much so that I'm reminded of the words
of tertullian who said that
the Salvation is the very hinge or
rather the flesh is the very hinge of
Salvation okay that our bodies and what
we do with our bodies when we do in time
and space really do matter so we should
not just become mulch okay you are more
than mulch you know in 2022 we launched
Jeremy's razors as a joke
but it was an important joke
now just nine months and 15 premium
products later we have amassed the
largest social media following of any
brand in the category and taken over 10
million dollars away from so-called
Men's Grooming companies that despise
masculinity but that was just the
beginning this year we've got even more
great products and woke scorching
Endeavors in store so skip the
resolutions Join the Revolution together
we will upend the woke economy and
finally give conservatives a return to
what we believe in are you ready to
really make a change this year
pick up Jeremy's razors Hair Skin beard
and body care products today by going to
dailywire.com Knowles that is
dailywire.com Knowles
Ron DeSantis
Ron DeSantis speaking of Christianity
was sworn into office again yesterday
and he did so on the Bible of the
Revolution this Bible
goes back to 1782 when the U.S Congress
endorsed the King James translation of
the eightkin Bible which printer Robert
Aitkin published after America won the
Revolutionary War it is the first and
only Edition ever commissioned
Rhonda Santos was able to borrow this
edition of the Bible from Glenn Beck
Glenn Beck as some of you may know has
probably the greatest collection of
American artifacts ever assembled he
just loves collecting this stuff and
he's got this very important Bible and
so Ron DeSantis takes the oath of office
on this Bible
Glenn Beck lent it to him because he
believes that Ron DeSantis is
governorship has real historical
significance his words it is the
beginning of a renewal of the principles
for which our Founders fought this is of
course just another signal that Ron
DeSantis is running for president in
2024
his wife looked absolutely beautiful at
the swearing and DeSantis doing all the
right things to do that and he's pulling
together a coalition of some people who
really liked Trump some people who like
Glenn Beck really didn't like Trump
certainly not in 2016. it's a signal
that Ron DeSantis is just pulling more
and more support together 2024 is a long
way off so I don't have many more
predictions to say about that sort of
thing but speaking of rising stars in
The GOP
George Santos George Santos who is the
newly elected Republican congressman
who lied about pretty much everything in
his past his ethnicity his job his
education potentially his sexual desires
everything he lied about everything
he's now under investigation in Brazil
he's under investigation I shouldn't
laugh but it's funny so I will laugh
when George Santos was 19 years old
he entered a clothing store in Brazil
and spent 700 bucks using a stolen
checkbook and a false name he then
allegedly admitted to the fraud on
Brazilian social media website he and
his mother allegedly admitted to police
in 2010 that he stole the checkbook to
make fraudulent purchases
the following year the a chart a legal
charge against Santos was approved but
he had already left the country he was
living in the U.S so now now this guy
might be indicted by Brazil
and it raises a real pickle here's the
pickle
I was talking to some friends and
relatives over the break talking about
George Santos they said you know those
cowardly Republicans I bet they're going
to seat George Santos they're going to
allow him to serve even though he's
clearly a pathological liar
I said yeah they probably will
because did George Santos ever claim to
be Native American for his whole career
when he was a Harvard Professor is that
oh no that was Elizabeth Warren did
George Santos he lied about his
education does he ever claimed to have
three degrees that he got on a full
academic scholarship after he was the
top student in his Department officially
named and oh no that was Joe Budden
who also plagiarized by the way
the pickle here is that
George Santos obviously has all sorts of
problems and does not seem to be the
most stable individual in the world
but the ire against him seems so
disingenuous because
Democrats and Libs get away with all the
same stuff and actually far worse
transgressions
it's how I feel about Andrew Tate
Andrew Tate is a pimp
I am not generally in the habit of
Defending pimps okay
but
for the libs to pretend to be up in arms
over and rotate sex trafficking because
he ran a webcam business
seems disingenuous when the libs turn a
blind eye to Jeffrey Epstein and to all
the other insane sexual behaviors that
they not only tolerate but actually
encourage
they themselves are the ones who are
pushing the sexual Revolution and who
are claiming that prostitution is real
work it's it's real work and we need to
legalize prostitution and all sorts of
deviant sexual behavior so it's just it
just Rings Hollow when they go after
Andrew Tate for that sort of stuff
it's there it's a real pickle that we
are in now
what are we to do about that
I think we can just acknowledge both
things
we don't need to really defend George
Santos or undertake all that hard
but I think we can observe hey you guys
who are clutching your pearls here
you're being very very disingenuous and
I'm I'm not going to prostrate myself at
the altar of liberalism and say no throw
these men to the Wolves no okay we'll
let the system work out as it may but
I'm going to keep Clear Eyes about what
the libs are doing okay now speaking of
trouble in foreign countries
trouble overseas in Queensland Australia
police are now asking citizens to snitch
on their fellow citizens if they ever
commit the terrible transgression of
entertaining a conspiracy theory
and we welcome that information as I
said before if it's anybody out there
that knows of someone that might be
showing concerning Behavior around you
know conspiracy theories anti-government
anti-police
um conspiracy theories around covid-19
vaccination as what we're seeing with
the train family we'd want to know about
we want to know about that and you can
either contact police directly or go
through Crime Stoppers
we want to know that
if there's anything I can't really do a
good Australian that's not a knife this
is a knife that's pretty much all I can
do crikey
they want to know if anyone is
entertaining a crazy conspiracy theory
like that the the MRNA vaccines are not
totally safe and effective
which was has been proven true time and
time again
the crazy conspiracy theory that maybe
the government is corrupt and has
demonstrated that corruption at an
international scale
over the past three years like has been
proven time and time again
the conspiracy theories we've said this
on the show for a long time now
the
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth over the last three
years is about three to six months we're
told
it's a crazy conspiracy theory that the
masks and the social distancing don't do
very much and then later come said oh
yeah actually that's probably right
crazy conspiracy theory that the
vaccines might cause heart problems and
blood clots and things like that that's
crazy conspiracy theory turns out
obviously that's true the crazy
conspiracy theory that the vaccines
won't stop you from getting coveted or
transmitting covet oh no it actually
that turns out that that was totally
true
even the Liberals admit this now even my
liberal friends and relatives they'll
say I said well I wasn't that vaccine
supposed to stop everybody from getting
coveted you know when they still wear
the masks and things you have you guys
have all the vaccines isn't that
supposed to stop you from getting
coveted and what do they tell me they
say no no actually Michael that's it at
first that's what they said but it
turned out
it turned out that actually none of that
was true yeah remember when I said that
from the very beginning and you all
called me crazy in a lunatic and a
murderer and you remember that no nobody
nobody remembers that
is that all to say
this is still going on
these clips that you're seeing come out
of especially Australia they're not from
three years ago okay this stuff is still
going on right now and it's part of a
broader plan that is being pushed by
some of the most powerful people in the
world not so secretly they're doing it
out in the open they're calling it The
Great reset this is a term coined by
Klaus Schwab who's the head of the world
economic Forum he published a book to
this effect you've had heads of state
you've had King Charles in England and
many many heads of state throughout the
world uh repeat this phrase that we need
a great reset that covid-19 presents a
terrific opportunity
to not just change some Health Care
policies but to upend our economies our
political rights the way the countries
interact with one another that is still
happening
that's not going to go away and they're
occasionally going to try to bring back
maybe the masks or the vaccine mandates
or they might sputter to try to do that
even as that has become so implausible
but the broader project which involves
changing the relationship of businesses
to the state what the sort of State can
mandate sort of surveillance that the
state is allowed to engage in
the medical knowledge that state actors
are allowed to take and the private
actors are allowed to take the blurring
between the public and the private which
is a key aspect of the world economic
Forum agenda that's why the world
economic Forum exists in the first place
is to create a tighter partnership
between the public sector and the
private sector
which is not it's not just communism
it's not just capitalism
it's this Blobby awful combination of
these two things the the this corrupt
Fusion of of people who want to take a
lot of power and a lot of money
and upend your way of life that is still
going on do not think that you have left
covid in the rear view mirror if
anything
it's just getting started
the rest of the show continues now today
is not Wednesday No it is Wednesday
right because we had Monday off I was
going to say it's woke Tuesday no it's
woke Wednesday
and we are going to have a wonderful
woke presentation The Producers have
prepared for me I will be reacting to it
I need your expertise to help me
decipher
the high level thinking in this work
message so if you want to become a
member which I know all of you do use
code Knoll scanner wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
right now at Daily wire plus use code
nulls we'll see over with member block
[Music]
foreign